[Music]
in fake J's news
Oh fake joints big J I love things
Jordans
wow that's what their does it look real
because Chinese people are so good at
making fakes it's just the exact same
[ __ ] except for a few my new details and
plus they're like half the price and you
don't give a [ __ ] about you know how
they do it they work in the factories
and they just turn the machines on at
night go and do the same yeah yeah yeah
yeah here's a whole mall that I went to
in Beijing that everything in there is
fake
now they're everything in it [ __ ] I
heard that there's a fake in and out in
China oh and Korea oh really yeah
what is it in and in sometimes out out
in in in the arrows not going sideways
it's going down it's like there's grains
of like fake Jordans too right there's
the one that's like plasticy it smells
funny it doesn't have that same shoe
smell there's a one that's like damn
near [ __ ] similar like stitch for
stitch except for a few minor details
and it has the same new shoes smell same
leather and that was like maybe like 50
or 60 bucks cheaper than the original
well this was submitted by do you like
nice shoes yes yeah who likes bad shoes
he's gonna say no to nice shoes cheap
shoes Simpson oh well you like them nice
don't you I mean yeah they've gotta look
I think everybody likes nice shoes
they're next nineties cousin got it in
Japan dude [ __ ] new buckin suede with
that gum bottom cuz Maui and son Maui
and Sons is it real well this was real
yeah but but Japan are like no tax or
some [ __ ]
no tax for foreigners five people have
been charged with trafficking seventy
three million in counterfeit Nike Air
Jordans
oh damn 73 73 that's a big business
that's a profit profitable Enterprise
million yeah you want or dollars on a
dog and
he's very correct is five Chinese people
that were arrested the Triads are those
people
oh my god that's a lot of money to split
with five people dude think about all
the money that the dry air jordans is
out that's true I know they lost seventy
three million dollars or their 1 billion
dollars but they some even cheaper too
so it's probably even more having the
Jordan issues they cost what like a
dollar to make and they sell it for
about 200 mm-hmm so their profit margins
is and they sell out in five seconds or
whatever yeah it's it's kind of crazy
like how much people will pay for shoes
because I'm part of that group not
anymore
like there are shoes that I really
really want that I will buy but now it's
just like I do look at the value it's
like they go this is rare no it's not it
was made in a factory there was no blind
Tibetan mock that's dishes just with
their [ __ ] hands but no it's rare
because they artificially control the
supply yeah like that like the Earl
Grey's and [ __ ] yeah so it's like was
that kind of for some reason when that
clicked it was like why is it Sharia
shoes not [ __ ] rare like right now
they had the bloop they could just make
it in the factory right now yeah but
they're not going to but that's like
pokemon cards man it's like one of these
is rare because they made seven of them
or whatever yeah yeah so for the last
two years this counterfeiting ring has
shipped 42 containers full of Air
Jordans and they would retell them for
about a hundred and ninety dollars per
pair and so the last fake ones are 190
this is impressed yeah getting duped man
that several companies wanting to do
brand deals with me that had like fake
sites get it what do they call them I
hit me up but they're like oh my god
these are authentic they're like no
they're look-alikes I'm like all you
[ __ ] I know is that bad grammar yeah
yeah you think they did they sold them
for the same price because it wanted to
pass them off as the same thing I
wouldn't yeah that's one of this one
hundred ninety bucks then yeah yeah
they're saying that's in the last eight
months investigators inspected 27,000
pairs of sneakers before they charge
these people and they they obviously
find out they're fake well they are real
cuz they're made at the same factory
with the same materials and the same
people that made the real ones yeah
what they would be doing though is that
they would ship all of these shoes to
Brooklyn and Queens like New York and
then they would have they would ship
these shoes without the logos and then
they would add the logos once they were
here that's how smart sometimes you
would get a bad fake Jordan and it would
be Jordan doing a dunk it's him doing a
layup yeah
once you have a free throw or it's like
that Scottie Pippen Jordan sitting on
the bench
Jordan silhouette pal yeah yeah where
he's doing baseball yeah why do they do
that like why do they make it wrong it's
like they could just if they're already
a parody shoe yeah I guess you know what
I mean I want parody that's shoes who's
in me I miss I miss the bad counterfeits
like in the 90s you guys remember those
like I had school friends that would
have ideas with like three stripes and
all five stripes it would be it would be
like five yeah my dad yeah we Morgan it
was like I'd be eyes yeah I have like
Simba I have like seven knockoff NFL
jerseys oh yeah it's just expensive oh
that's crazy
no out of like 15 I like 15 jerseys half
of my call any apples called stirred
Zeke oceans and I still got my Brian
grant and Mitch Richmond Sacramento
Kings baked Jersey right now in my
closet fits like a wet suit you still
have it
yeah if it's like a wet team that's not
good it's [ __ ] tight because I had it
oh yeah so it's like when I was a kid I
still have it still we're proud did you
did your parents ever buy you bootleg
toys from the swap meet yeah like and
they were the best it'll be like super
guy it's not Superman it's like looks
like Superman yeah or light his hair
split down the middle it's just off or
like it looks like spider-man but like
with the spot with a Superman costume
it's all [ __ ] up you know I didn't
know that brass knuckles and [ __ ] were
[ __ ] illegal until I brought them to
school no felony here yeah I didn't know
that because I got at the swap meet
yeah they have all those weapons over
here elementary school with two brass
knuckles of [ __ ] yokai
but I got in trouble because I was like
what is [ __ ] like I did it you know
you thought they're just ringing no I
knew what they were for but I thought it
was okay to have them cuz it's just
metal on your hands it's like yeah yeah
well exactly rings I know the same thing
right but I got in trouble cuz it so
whatever you can buy them right now cuz
we are I was doing some producing first
kit that we were doing and we needed
these types of weapons and I'm like
we're gonna go ahh and then just like
Chinatown Chinatown I guarantee you get
on eBay king over stereo yeah that's
true cuz other states I think it's ok
you know we can have nunchucks as
display but we can't walk around with it
or like there's certain weapons that
like if you have it in the house to
collect it's okay nunchucks are like the
least threatening looking weapon I've
ever seen I know but you see guys we are
nunchucks like it just makes me laugh
because what makes me nervous I'm like
you're gonna hit yourself exactly
because the fight is between you and
yourself but it's actually a hard
espresso it's a it's a you could get hit
with a crazier like penalty like you
could get [ __ ] [ __ ] up the ass if
you have moon chucks walk around with
this [ __ ] and you get caught with this
[ __ ] it's like a felony loaded gun
misdemeanor that's crazy
that's crazy flamethrowers are okay yes
yeah the laws are all weird and this is
in California to tell you about shoes
man like I feel like shoes is like the
hood status symbol you know it made
suits that and jewelry yeah like if
y'all change overs like I remember that
first time I bought those [ __ ] high
top of white airmax ones yeah I want a
gold rope like Run DMC still I know know
what a fat [ __ ] like the Silk Road
yeah like a like a like there's like a
gold chain like mr. t
Oh gross one big yeah I want a silk rope
I want that so wrong we buy that right
now as
no but I want to wait until I've earned
it okay Gio what what what when is that
earned when he's a rapper no when I've
no I've sold a couple more sounded oh
yeah the robe or the gold chain I'll do
the Rope the Rope you could buy that
right now no no but there's a really
tight one come on you talking about the
Versace one yes exactly the precise ones
are sick you ever know this black with
gold you ever noticed like when like
black people they wear like like the
dopest [ __ ] like how expensive like dope
fancy [ __ ] and he makes me hit my it
looks dope when you put that same person
and it's a white person you look like a
[ __ ] loser you do yeah what the [ __ ]
is that about
well by beaver horn maybe that's exactly
that [ __ ] do cuz I saw that the other
day this dude was that target and he was
just like decked out his [ __ ] I was
looking I was like man I I just want to
rock this dude what if it was a black it
was like that [ __ ] looks dope right so
weird if Jimmy delaghetto didn't act
black he wouldn't be as tough but
because he does and he's a friend of
mine Tom doesn't even wear half the [ __ ]
he does yeah I would look at school like
he has necklaces and like all the stuff
like I can run I get so jealous of all
that [ __ ] and and and a black people
shoes in general like they can wear just
like a shoe that's all red and it
doesn't look like [ __ ] on them that's
where that [ __ ] be really what the [ __ ]
are you wearing
they look like a pet fossil right I do
oh it's so weak I look like I look like
I look like a soccer dad who's trying to
connect with like he is like dude yeah
it's kind of weird like that like it's
just so weird I kind of felt myself
feeling weird about it I'll say why
don't we think like that use it okay
there's some white people that can pull
it off though like it's like yeah like
they're like dancers and stuff like they
know how to blend now they look like mr.
Holland's Opus do it it's like it's like
you're trying to connect with these kids
it's like nah dude it's like the mom
then [ __ ] mean girls dude yes yeah
that's exactly what it comes off as
yeah one where all blues should be so
sick you can't I can't
you gotta do it your way though oh yeah
exactly yeah
and so it's over before it began before
it began the fight is done is your the
nunchuck guy you know exactly we can't
pull it off or the Eastern Europeans
will they've no self-awareness they're
always the guys who wear those like like
pink little polo shirts and [ __ ]
yeah at hardy shirts still till this day
that's true they're stuck in 2003 yeah
then I'm on the mirror again the True
Religions only customer okay affliction
made millions coz of them oh yeah I
don't have an honest mirror they need
honest mirrors not whatever the [ __ ]
somebody is out there right now and you
guys have those [ __ ] in the Jordan
threes the sole version the Korean
version that came out of South Korea I
want those and so sell it to him decent
price though please give me a good price
please what's the going price for those
things retails like six thousand dollars
right now oh my god holy [ __ ]
so what's what's a decent price three
thousand huh I would pay a max of 800
bucks oh my god because they're you're
the reason why these fools have a
business because I don't like to sell
it's fake doors for if you make fake
ones adults like a buy already you're
like no would you buy the fake one yeah
100% would why wouldn't why wouldn't he
yeah how would you feel like someone's
re counterfeiting secret society they
already counterfeited go for broke
that's true oh then whatever I don't get
a fence I was kind of proud that our
stuff was out there to the poor people
counterfeit it that's funny yeah you're
[ __ ] vain person I don't think I'm
cool guy who's like who looks on Twitter
and he he like looks for somebody whose
name selves David so so he can be like
look see I need to be verified and line
up like a Christmas tree like yeah
they're trying to copy my name I don't
know that you could get verified on
Twitter you can and they still won't
verify me cuz people are like why aren't
you verifying Twitter site
[ __ ]
[Music]